controversé depuis qu'a commencé la
crise sanitaire le professeur de
médecine marseillais didier rahout va
devoir s'expliquer devant les instances
disciplinaires de l'ordre des médecins
cette convocation dévoilé ce jeudi par
le conseil national de l'ordre des
médecins découle d'une plainte déposée
en juillet dernier par la société de
pathologie infectieuse de langue
française
d'après le magazine paris match l'aspiq
reproche au médecin d'avoir utilisé des
traitements non validé ainsi que d'avoir
manqué aux devoirs de confraternité
didier rahout avait également fait
l'objet de plusieurs signalements de
patients mais aussi d'autres médecins va
arrêter d'être dans les débats
scientifiques au et kiko politico
médiatique on va arrêter d'être dans la
vindicte populaire
en tout cas de cette frange marginale de
la profession pourrait être sur le
terrain rigoureux du droit et sur le
terrain du droit d'y lire house
effectivement n'a absolument rien à
craindre de deux voilà deux ordres des
médecins n'a rien à craindre
effectivement que cette comparution
vaches en tipi nerfs je le redis il a
hâte en ce que il entend effectivement
s'expliquer précisément et sortira de là
avec son honneur lavé la question qu'on
peut raisonnablement se poser en
sera-t-il de même pour les institutions
ordinales ou alors est-ce qu'elles ne
seront pas ridiculiser mi-septembre le
microbiologiste avait déjà été entendu
par la commission d' enquête du sénat
seul face aux sénateurs ils avaient
défendu son traitement l'hydroxyde
rockin contre le nouveau coronavirus lui
qui mène depuis plusieurs mois des
essais cliniques avec cette molécule
toutefois l'efficacité de ce remède
contre le coc u19 n'a pas été établie
c'est pas moi qui développe l'anxiété je
les dis encore la semaine dernière
donc c'est pas moi qui développement que
c'était donc le l'interdiction prescrire
tout le monde c est bon opinion dessus
si vous voulez mais là encore je vois
pas comment on aurait pu avoir un débat
serein quand en espace de 2 d'une demi
journée
on sait le ministère et l'om et s'est
mis à dire on interdit par poules
hydroxy chloroquine parce que ça tue les
gens pour un papier qui a été retiré
trois semaines après parce que c'était
une bande de pieds nickelés qui avait
écrit ce truc dont personne ne savait
d'où il sortait donc c'est à moi qui
raconte des bêtises quand même ça au
bout d'un moment il faut revenir sur
terre c'est pas moi
à quand des bêtises accusé de plusieurs
entorses à la déontologie
didier rahout aura le temps de se
préparer avant d'être auditionné par ses
pairs d'après le conseil national de
l'ordre des médecins
le délai de traitement de ce type de
plainte est en moyenne de 10 mois